Welcome to our latest video where we
dive into the captivating world of cyber
security trends for 2024 data breaches
remain a Hot Topic especially in light
of recent high-profile incidents like
the 23 and me data breach where
sensitive genetic information was
potentially compromised we then turn to
the Fidelity National Financial Cyber
attack a stark reminder of the
vulnerabilities in the financial sector
where millions of records were at risk
in this Tech heavy era staying ahead of
cyber security threats is more crucial
than ever today we are unraveling the
complex web of digital security and
exploring the latest advancements and
challenges that Define the cyber
security landscape and before commencing
just a quick info for you if you are an
aspiring cyber security professional
looking for an online training and
certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns post-graduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice through our course you
will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen of others the course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% of average
you require no prior programming
experience and one plus year of work
experience is preferred if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comments and description box so
first we have is AI fishing so as we
step into 2024 think of fishing attacks
evolving into a much more advanced game
almost like they are supercharged that's
what AI fishing is all about it's like
the usual email scams but far more
clever and harder to spot here's the
twist these attacks use artificial
intelligence to craft messages that are
incredibly convincing and tailored just
for you you they dig through heaps of
your online data maybe a tweet here and
email there and then they hit you with a
message that seems like it's from a
friend or a legit company it's Sneaky
because it's so personalized making it
way easier to fall for it this isn't
your run off the M fishing it's like the
scammer knows you so in 2024 our fight
against fishing isn't just about being
cautious it's about being ready for
these smart AI driven tricks that can
tool even the saviest of us all right
the next trend on the list is Automotive
hacking so in 2024 our cars are not just
vcl they are like the smartphones on
Wheels constantly connected to the
internet now this is super cool because
your car can do a lot more but here's
the catch it's also open to cyber
attacks just like hackers can get into
your computer or phone they can
potentially mess with your car too they
could unlock it start it or even control
it remotely scary right so what should
we do about it well car companies and
Tech experts are working hard to beef up
security they're using tough encryption
to protect cars data think of it like a
secret code that only your car
understands they're also putting in
strong authentication checks kind of
like needing both a password and a
fingerprint to start your car plus
they're constantly monitoring the car
system to catch any hackers activities
right away it's all about making sure
that as our car gets smarter they also
get safer all right so this was about
Automotive hacking now moving on to the
next one which is deep fakes all right
let's talk about deep fakes a topic
that's quite different from the cyber
security of a connected cars deep fakes
are these incredibly realistic fake
videos or audio recordings made using
artificial intelligence imagine a video
here it looks like a famous person is
saying by something they never actually
did so this technology uses AI
algorithms to analyze real footage of
people and then creates new fake content
where it can manipulate the words
expressions or actions also now how does
this tie into cyber security so deep fix
present a formidable Threat by
potentially being weaponized to spread
misinformation manipulate public opinion
or even engage in extortion and
blackmailing individuals they are so
convincing that it's getting harder to
tell what's real and what's not for
someone unaware it's easy to be fooled
as this technology becomes more
accessible the potential for misuse
increases it's important to be critical
of the media we consume and stay aware
of the power and potential risk of deep
fake technology so this was about deep
faks the next one on the list is
potential of artificial intelligence AI
isn't just a buzz word it's a
GameChanger in cyber security think of
it as a double edged swad on on one side
it's revolutionized defense with
automated security systems smart enough
to understand human language recognize
faces and even spot threats before the
hit these AI systems are like Vigilant
guards constantly learning and
pretending new types of attacks
instantly alerting the admins if
something fishy pops up but here's the
catch the bad guys are using AI too
crafting smart malware that can sneak
past the latest security measures so
while AI is a smart Shield it's also
powering some really clever cyber
attacks so this was about it now coming
to the next trend on the list which is
data breaches yes in 2024 data breaches
are a major concern for everyone from
small business to large corporations and
even government think of it like this
our world is more digital than ever
almost everything we do is online or
stored on a computer system somewhere
this makes protecting a digital
information super important now with
everything going digital hackers are
always finding new ways to break into
systems a small mistake in software or
even using an outdated browser can be
you're leaving your front door unlocked
for cyber criminals they can sneak in
and steal your personal information like
your photos emails or financial data but
here's the good part there are laws to
protect us like the gdpr in Europe and
the CCPA in California they are all
about keeping a data safe and giving us
rights over our own information so in a
nutshell data reaches in 2024 are all
about staying one step ahead of hackers
and making sure our Digital Life is
locked up tight so this was about data
breaches now moving forward to the
targeted ransomware so in targeted
ransomware has become a major concern in
2024 especially for organization in
developing countries that depend heavily
on specific software picture this
instead of random attacks these cyber
threats are laser focus like the vanak
attack that hit in England and Scotland
National Health Service crippling over
70,000 medical devices it's not just
about demanding ransomware anymore these
attacks can seriously disrupt large
organization or even entire nations they
don't just look up your data and ask for
money they can bring vital operations to
standstill creation chaos and severe
consequences so it's like having cyber
bugler who knows exactly which valuable
is to steal so after targeted ransomware
the the next one on the list is
multiactor authentication or MFA so
think of multiactor authentication or
MFA as a security guard that checks two
IDs instead of one before letting you
into your online accounts it's like
adding an extra lock on your door
normally you just use passwords right
but with MFA you also need something
else maybe a code sent to your phone or
your fingerprint it's way tougher for
hackers to break into your accounts
because they need both pieces your
password and this extra bit it's super
important for businesses to use MFA it's
like an extra layer of armor against
cyber attex making sure only the right
people gets it plus with automation
playing a big role in cyber security MFA
becomes even more efficient and less
prone to mistakes unlike when we do
things manually automation speeds up
detecting threats and responding to them
making everything safer and smoother
following this there is
iot so iot or Internet of Things The
Internet of Things is booming thanks to
5G networks making super fast seamless
connections between devices a reality
imagine your fridge car watch and phone
all chatting with each other but here's
the catch this cool Tech also makes our
gadgets more vulnerable they could be
hit by cyber attacks or bugs just like
Google Chrome has experienced the thing
is 5G is still pretty new and we are all
figuring out its weak spots with every
step into this 5G world we are possibly
walking into unknown cyber threats that
could take advantage of these connected
devices so this was about the weak
Sports and iot now moving on to the next
one which is cloud security threats so
Cloud security threats are a big deal
think of it Cloud as massive digital
storage locker where companies keep
their data it's super convenient but
also a big Target for hackers these
threats come in many forms from stealing
data to hijacking computing resources
Etc imagine someone breaking into your
Cloud locker and swiping sensitive
information or using it to do Shady
stuff like launching other cyber attacks
it's not just about losing data it's
about unauthorized access that can
disrupt entire businesses so keeping the
cloud service is like having a top note
security for your most valuable digital
assets all right so this was about the
cyber security trends of 2024 as we wrap
up our journey through the cyber
security trends of 2024 it's it's clear
that digital world is evolving rapidly
bringing both Innovative opportunities
and challenging threats from the cunning
AI fishing to the complexities of cloud
security we have seen how staying
Vigilant and informed is more crucial
than ever remember cyber security is not
just about a one-time effort it's about
continuous battle against ever evolving
threats so keep adapting stay updated
and always be proactive in safeguarding
your digital presence thank you for
joining us in exploring these pivotal
trends stay safe online and hairs to
secure a digital future staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs and Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here